[Applaudissements]
sial pour touche pas à mon pote je
voulais pas vous le dire depuis le début
mais c'est un jour qui pour moi va
changer certainement ma vie mais je vous
le dis non seulement j'ai lu le livre de
kenji aujourd'hui mais il ya autre chose
qui se passe aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui il ya quelqu'un qui a grandi
il ya quelqu'un qui a mûri il y a
quelqu'un qui est devenu et gris c'est
juste pour la rime il ya une personne
dont c'est l'anniversaire aujourd'hui
cette personne c'est quelqu'un qui m'est
cher c'est quelqu'un avec qui j'ai
partagé plein de choses on a partagé des
bises à la baule iten n'a partagé des
caprices des dieux et bientôt partagera
notre vie c'est l'anniversaire dit ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elissa
[Applaudissements]
m
c'est à dire service à calage dans la
zac ims à quel âge as-tu
jésus il a 33 10 à 0 vous avez donc des
dents se sont pas dit janine oui bien
sûr s'est ouvert sur les jeunes filles
viendront avec vous souffle on a alors
vous avez remarqué qu'on a encore un
petit budget 1 ce qui est à prendre
trois ans on a mis cinq bougies toi ma
non plus à faire non plus allez-y merci
beaucoup en tout cas c'est gentil
m
voilà c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
merci les danseurs merci merci est-ce
que je peux me permettre de faire un
petit truc
est ce que vous pouvez me traiter ça
c'est vrai tu parle espagnol l'a
pourtant que tout l'été tâche s'annonce
en tout cas près des motos cas là c'est
tout près témoin tout ça te motive pas
parce qu'on ne sait pas c'est vrai veut
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]